at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking another question I must -
etiquette is living tissue over metal
endoskeleton this episode is brought to
you by teeter I am so thrilled to have
connected with these guys because I've
used teeter products for many many years
I've traveled around the country and the
world with teeter products and I'm
sitting about 15 feet in my home from
one of their inversion tables and we're
gonna talk more about all of that one of
my rituals is hanging and I should say
not really that it's a maintenance and
performance program I hang not just in
the morning potentially but particularly
after a day of bearing weight whether
that includes weight training in Jersey
Greg rec world record-holder
insists on this type of inversion
therapy after training or just wearing
heavy backpack around a few minutes goes
a long way towards better sleep in my
case less back pain neck pain leg pain
it's not a panacea obviously but
inversion therapy which uses gravity and
your own bodyweight to decompress the
spine and relieve pressure on the discs
and surrounding nerves seems to help
with a whole slew of conditions and just
as a general maintenance program it's
one of my favorite things to do so what
to say about that teeter why Teeter
Teeter is the best known name in
inversion table since 1981 more than 3
million people have put their trust in
Teeter Teeter is also the only inversion
table brand that has been both safety
certified by Underwriters Laboratories
that's ul for you people in that
industry you will recognize it and
registered with the FDA as a class 1
medical device and they're giving a very
special offer just to you guys my
listeners for a limited time you can get
the teeter inversion table with bonus
accessories which I have a bunch of
again in the room next to me and a free
pair of gravity boots so that you can
invert at home or take the boots with
you to the gym so these gravity boots I
have 3
separate pairs of gravity boots bought
with my own money z' in three different
cities that I've had for a very very
long time because I don't want to travel
with them necessarily it look kind of
like ski boots but without the foot
portion and they hook you upside down so
you can take them really anywhere you
want to go to get this deal which is a
savings of over a hundred and forty
eight dollars it's very specific so
maybe it's a hundred forty nine you have
to go to Teeter dot-com forward slash
Tim that's Teeter comm /tm te e ter you
also see a free shipping a 60 day money
back guarantee and free returns so why
not try it out remember you can only get
the teeter inversion table with bonus
accessories and a free pair of gravity
boots by going to teeter comm forward
slash Tim so if you're thinking to
yourself what the hell is this thing
he's talking about I can't even envision
it in my head well take a look at the
photos go to Teeter comm forward slash
Tim this episode is brought to you by
helix sleep last year I committed to
making sleep a top priority trying to
fix onset insomnia or continuing to fix
that depth of sleep quality of sleep I
tracked a lot I tested a lot and I
revisited really everything from the
daily routine to these surfaces I slept
on playing with a chili pad whatever and
when I moved to Austin I got all new
beds including mattresses from helix
working with the world's leading sleep
expert certainly some of them helix
sleep developed mattresses personalized
to your preferences and sleep style to
make sure that you can have the best
sleep possible without costing thousands
upon thousands of dollars helix sleep
has recently added a new layer to
customize sleep with the helix pillow
the all-new pillows are fully adjustable
so you can achieve perfect comfort
regardless of a sleep position or body
type or if you're a shifty type like me
I move around quite a bit when I sleep
just take their simple two to three
minute sleep quiz to get started and
that will help ensure that they can
build a mattress or pillow that you will
love the mattress whatever this bespoke
mattress is that you arrive at will get
to you within a week and the shipping is
completely free you can try the mattress
for 100 nights and if you're not
completely
happy they'll pick it up and offer a
full refund I tested that refund policy
because I test all of these sponsors and
kick the tires a lot we tested it and
they came through on making sure that we
got ultimately the right mattress for my
body type to personalize your sleep
experience visit helix sleep comm
forward slash Tim and you'll receive up
to 125 dollars off your mattress order
that's helix sleep hgl is sleep comm
forward slash tim for up to one hundred
twenty five dollars off your order hello
boys and girls ladies and germs this is
Tim Ferriss and welcome to a very
special episode of the Tim Ferriss show
I'm going to start this off with a quote
quote what the telescope was for
astronomy and the microscope for biology
psychedelics will be for the
understanding of the human mind that is
attributed to stanislav grof this
episode you're going to hear I've been
looking forward to recording for more
than a year now it might be the most
important episode that I've put out in
the last two to three years so please
trust me and give it a full listen even
if you don't think it will interest you
at all it will surprise you perhaps
shock you and definitely make you think
differently Michael Pollan's newest book
and this is his first podcast about it
is my new favorite of his it is titled
how to change your mind
subtitle what the new science of
psychedelics teaches us about
consciousness dyeing addiction
depression and transcendence this is an
episode that will explore not just the
science and applications of psychedelics
but also Michaels personal exploration
it's quite a wild ride for those who
don't know who Michael Pollan is on
Twitter at Michael Pollan he's the
author of seven previous books including
cooked food rules in defense of food The
Omnivore's Dilemma also a great book and
the botany of desire also a fantastic
book all of which were New York Times
bestsellers a longtime contributor to
the New York Times Magazine he also
teaches writing at Harvard and the
University of California at Berkeley
where he is the Jon s and James L Knight
professor of science journalism in 2010
Time magazine named him one of the 100
influential people in the world this is
also where I want to make a public
announcement and that is partially due
to Michael's book I am committing a
million dollars over the next few years
to supporting scientific study of
psychedelic compounds this is for me by
far the largest commitment to research
and nonprofits that I've ever made and
if you'd like to perhaps join me in
supporting at a higher level
check out Tim blog forward slash science
it's Tim blog forward slash science but
why would I do this across the board
I've done a number of things in the
scientific realm and the molecules
discussed in this episode and some
incredible clinical results from
well-designed studies have absolutely
captured my attention over the last two
years and after waiting in and
supporting some smaller studies seeing
the results I've decided to go all in on
scientists exploring this area it just
seems to be an Archimedes lever for
potentially solving a wide range of root
cause problems instead of playing
whack-a-mole with symptoms one by one so
this episode will explain why I'm so
goddamn excited and all that preamble
out of the way grab a cup of coffee
relax put your seat back settle in and I
really hope you enjoy this conversation
as much as I did without further ado
here is Michael Pollan
Michael welcome to the show thank you to
him good to be here I am so thrilled to
be sitting down to have this
conversation and I thought back to when
we first met and I believe I owe some
thanks to Matt Mullenweg
the CEO of automatic because I believe
that I attended an event he had
organized that might have been for the
Omnivore's Dilemma I think it was
perhaps in defense of food but I've I
followed your career for so long and
read so many of your books I thought one
place we could start is with the the
conception of Michael Pollan as food
writer and perhaps we could start off
with you just describing how the new
book came to be how did you end up
writing this new book sure well to go
back I think we met at a benefit for
Grist yes that is right that was there
and that was also involved it was around
the time of in defense of food or food
rules or something yeah
at Tony Conrad's house that's right huh
I'd say yeah back years yeah but I think
that was the first time we met
so yeah this book does certainly seem
like a departure for me and in some ways
it is but in other ways I see it is very
continuous with the kind of work I've
been doing as I see it I think of myself
as a kind of nature writer I really like
writing about the engagement of humans
with other species and I've been doing
that since my first book which was a
book called second nature which was
really about what was going on in my
garden and I've always been interested
in the fact that we have these symbiotic
relationships that were active
participants in nature not just
spectators and that we have and that the
the usual American way of thinking about
nature that we inherit from Thoreau and
Emerson and John Muir is of a very
passive relationship and I've always as
a gardener I've always been interested
in the more active where
the way we use plants and the way they
in turn use us so if that's the kind of
spine or the the trunk of my work all
the food work is kind of a big fat
branch off of that and that's you know
looking at what is one of our most
powerful engagements with the natural
world which is agriculture which you
know changes nature more than anything
else we do really so I've been on that
branch for now for books I guess and but
I've never lost interest in the other
ways we engage with the natural world
and one of the most curious of these
which I touched on in in a book called
botany of desire was the fact that we
use plants to change our experience of
consciousness and a very select group of
plants and fungi has evolved the
chemistry that does that with varying
degrees of disruption and I've always
been curious as to why such a desire and
it is a universal human desire there's
not a culture on earth that doesn't use
some plant or fungi fungi to change
consciousness with one notable exception
the Inuit and the only reason they don't
is none of that stuff grows there and so
what's that desire about what good is it
for us to change consciousness why do
why do people seek it so that's you know
that's kind of been a theme of my work
that I've never fully explored in a book
until this one until how to change your
mind
so there is that continuity in my mind
and it is part of a larger narrative
that I've always been interested in and
then there's the fact that I'm you know
intensely interested in health I've been
writing about health in my last couple
books on food you know we have a
situation where our biggest physical
health problems are chronic diseases
linked to our diet but we also of course
suffer from a real crisis in mental
health and that also made me very
interested to take a look at
psychedelics since they promise to to
contribute to solving that problem
did did that interest in exploring
psychedelics this is gonna be a very
memento like conversation
chronologically we'll probably bounce
around quite a bit did that begin with
the article about psychedelic
psychotherapy in The New Yorker called
the trip treatment did it precede that
how did how did that piece yeah that was
my first real foray I think I talked
about psychedelics briefly in botany of
desire and quoted all this Huxley and
the idea of the reducing valve and
whether we had a more accurate or less
accurate picture of the world when when
high but yeah my Seerat my first serious
forward for a was I'd heard this
remarkable about this remarkable
research using psychedelics psilocybin
in particular magic mushrooms or the
ingredient magic mushrooms to treat
people who had cancer diagnoses and this
seems so improbable to me
I couldn't imagine wanting to take a
psychedelic when confronting my
mortality
that I became very curious to explore it
and so embarked on what was almost a
year-long project looking at psilocybin
and talking to dozens of people cancer
patients some of them still alive some
of them no longer alive and how this
single experience a high-dose psilocybin
experience administered with a guide you
know in a very controlled setting had
completely reset their thinking about
mortality had given them a mystical
experience that dissolved their egos and
made them think about their place in the
world in such a novel way or their sense
of their own self-interest as so broad
that dying lost its sting and completely
in some cases I remember this one woman
I talked to who had her name was a Dyna
bizarre she was a figure skating
instructor in New York City and she was
in the early 60s and
she had ovarian cancer and she was
absolutely paralyzed by the fear of a
recurrence even though she you know had
a successful course of of therapy and
she she had a psilocybin journey and she
went into her body and under her rib
cage
she confronted this black mass it wasn't
her tumor cause it wasn't in her you
know where her ovaries would be it was
under her rib cage and she realized it
wasn't her tumor it was her fear and she
screamed at it she said get the [ __ ] out
of my body and she said it vanished and
from then on she had no fear and in the
article for The New Yorker I did the
usual play it safe journalist thing
where I said and after the experience
her fear had been substantially
diminished or something that I thought
would slip past the back deck and as we
tend to do and they called her though
and check the quote with her and and she
said no that's completely wrong it was
not diminished my fear was eliminated
and what she explained is I learned
during that psilocybin trip that though
I couldn't control the cancer I could
control the fear and that was just
life-changing for her so reading about
these experiences which seemed you know
too good to be true almost almost
implausible I became more and more
interested in going deeper you know as a
journalist there there are two kinds of
articles we write there they're the ones
where we exhaust the subject and we're
so sick of it we can't wait to move on
and then they're the ones where we
realize you know I've only scratched the
surface here and this was one of those I
had only scratched the surface there was
so much more to learn and then there was
also this mounting curiosity to have
some experiences in my own we are
definitely going to explore that terrain
I thought one very helpful aspect of the
book is the glossary of terms that you
include in the beginning mm-hm and it's
actually in the end of the printed
version oh it is all right so I received
it free
pre-publication copy i moved it to the
back it just felt a little textbook heat
confronted first it is very textbook II
but it's it helps provide people with
weather at the back of the book of the
beginning definitions that I think can
can help to inform the conversation so
for people who have heard the term no
doubt psychedelic or psychedelics I but
are unclear on exactly what that refers
to
can you could you define that what are
psychedelics sure I'd be happy to I'd be
happy to try you know one of the
interesting aspects of the story of the
history of what we'll call psychedelics
for reasons I'll explain is that the
name kept changing because people really
didn't understand these molecules they
were so strange so at first they were
called psychotics this is in the early
50s soon after LSD was made available to
researchers and ceccato mimetic
basically meant it was a psychoactive
drug that mimicked psychosis and lots of
psychiatrists would look at the what
happened to people and say well they're
having a psychotic episode turned out to
be wrong but it sure looked that way and
and then they then other people called
it a psycho lytic which means mind
loosening and they were using it in
basically in your typical talk therapy
session as a way to loosen lytic means
mind loosening people's defenses and
allow them to get in touch with
subconscious thoughts and emotions
psychedelic as a term is coined in 1957
by a key figure in this history named
Humphry Osmond Osmond is an English
psychiatrist who moves to Saskatchewan
because the provincial government was
willing to let him study whatever he
wanted which happened to be mescaline
and LSD and they had a very progressive
Health Department in Saskatchewan and he
he got involved with Aldous Huxley and
in fact is the person responsible for
giving Aldous Huxley his first mescaline
experience and they correspond it
extensively as people used to do and in
one of their cars
fondants they were they were trying to
come up with a better word for these
drugs because they simply didn't believe
it was true that it made people crazy in
fact they believed they could make
people sane so they went back and forth
and Osmond ironically enough not the
brilliant writer came up with a good
term that stuck and that was psychedelic
and that essentially all that means is
mind manifesting that these are
compounds that help the mind
manifest its its deepest qualities and
it caught on and we think of it as a
very kind of sixties term associated
with Timothy Leary and in the
counterculture but in fact it was coined
by a psychiatrist in the 50s so it
simply means mind manifesting and I use
it to refer to what are sometimes called
the classical psychedelics I tend not to
think of MDMA as a psychedelic even
though some people do or or cannabis as
a psychedelic but that group of
chemicals that include mescaline DMT
psilocybin magic mushrooms and LSD and
there and there's a handful of others
that are unified by the fact that they
work on similar receptor network in the
brain and have roughly similar effects
on the mind
you know on the phenomenology of the
experience so that's really when I talk
about psychedelics that's what I've got
in mine and the phenomenology you mean
these subjective the reporting of the
subjective experience the felt
experience yeah it's a very fancy word
for how it feels I
why did you dedicate this book to your
father
ah well for a couple reasons some of
which I didn't understand till I
finished the book I did it because my
dad was very sick for most of the time I
was writing it he he himself had
terminal cancer and died of lung cancer
in earlier this year in January so I
wanted it was my last chance to dedicate
a book to him or at least one that he
would see he didn't get to read it so I
thought I would do
but as I've thought about it since I
realized this book is you know very much
about him a friend of mine read the book
and said wow your father's on every page
and I didn't know what that meant
exactly but I've since given it some
thought and I realized that one of the
reasons I got so interested in the
experience of cancer and and and that
that confrontation with one's mortality
is that my dad was going through that
but unlike the patients I was talking to
the volunteers and the psilocybin
experience he really didn't want to talk
about it and it was just a conversation
we couldn't have and we had a lot of
conversations in his last year or two
but for whatever reason I don't really
understand how he was processing what
was coming because he really wouldn't
share it and so in a sense I was I was
having conversations I wanted to have
with him
although I was certainly afraid to in
some ways I was having those
conversations with these other people
these these strangers who I got to know
and and hearing how they thought about
their death and how psilocybin changed
how they thought about their death
really became a proxy for a conversation
I never had with my father what effect
did that have on you I mean if if
anything jumps out I mean is there any
salient effects that had on you did you
do you did you end up feeling a sense of
of closure or resolution in some way uh
you know in a way I wish my father had
been able to have one of these
experiences I don't know that he would
have gone for it
you know he's of such a different
generation he was probably too old to
qualify he was 88 when he died but it's
kind of a black box you know that was a
generation didn't always talk about
these things and I do think it had an
effect on me in that having given so
much thought to death and the process
and the afterlife as psychedelics makes
you do I
think in his last weeks and months and
days I was more available to him than I
would have been I you know I think that
I was not as fearful or as defensive is
probably a better word you know one of
the things our egos defend us against
his death one of the big things and so
when were confronted by it we figure out
a million ways to think about something
else or turn away if we can but I was
very present for his death I was with
him and my mother in the apartment for
the last week and I didn't feel there
was any barrier I felt like I was able
to say everything I needed to say to be
physically available to him so in a
sense I think my own my own psychedelic
experience isn't the amount of thought
I'd given to to dying because of that
article I'd worked on probably made me a
better caregiver in some way since and
and better able to process what was
happening and and you know I guess I did
a lot of preparation too because I saw
it coming for a couple years that takes
you know that takes away none of the
power of the experience but I do think
if you know it's funny some some
journalists I've just started doing
interviews on this book and one of the
questions you get asked is how did your
own experiences change you and that's a
hard question to answer it's it's it's
subtle in some ways but it was my wife
who said well I really think you would
have you would have been different
around your father at the end if you
hadn't had those experiences and you
know I think she's probably right based
on all of my reading of your work based
on the the conversations I've observed
you having and our limited exchanges
that we've had you've always struck me
as a very open-minded journalist while
very skeptical which is a good
combination for the profession you've
chosen what were you most skeptical of
going into the process of saying
considering a book on this topic and did
you go in with the intention of having
your own
I didn't go in with that intention when
I started the New Yorker article I
didn't know it was possible to have
obviously you can have a psychedelic
experience if you can find the drugs but
I mean to have the sort of orchestrated
guided experience which i think is if
people need to understand is a
fundamentally different way of using the
same chemical but the experience is like
very different and it was actually in
the course of working on that article
that I kept getting like these whispers
that there was this underground and that
you know there was a kind of shadow
world not too far away from the you know
the legit researchers I was I was
interviewing and so I started getting
Inklings that that might be possible but
I I'm not a I'm not a psycho nod and I
was not I had very little experience I
mean I it was kind of odd I just kind of
came of age at a little wrinkle in time
where there weren't a lot of
psychedelics around and by the time they
were available to me I was I was
terrified of that my men I'm sort of
more a product of the moral panic
against psychedelics than of the
psychedelic 60s I mean just to give you
an idea I was 12 during the summer of
love I was 14 during Woodstock so this I
was a little you know I came a little
late to the party and the party was
getting pretty sour already you know the
scene in San Francisco had gotten really
sour and there was a lot of bad
information but scary information about
psychedelics that were out there so this
wasn't a natural thing for me and you
know what you call my skepticism is
journalistic skepticism but it's also
you know plain old fear and you know
wondering is this for real
I did have skepticism I think that the
results of these studies which hadn't
been published when I published on them
it was quite it was very much to the New
Yorkers credit they were willing to let
me do 14 thousand words on essentially a
scientific research that hadn't been
peer
you'd yet and but I gradually became
convinced by the you know the authority
of the people who were talking to me
that they had had had had these
transformative experiences I tend to but
I do write about psychedelics and I
think that's this is somewhat unique
about the book with one foot outside of
this world and only one foot in it and I
think that that distance is very
important for various reasons I think
it's important to remain critical as a
journalist and when you see things that
are being hyped and you know that that
may well happen with psychedelics it's
something I I'm concerned about but also
as a way in for readers who may not be
experienced or may have their own doubts
or fears I become a surrogate for the
reluctant traveler and and that's you
know that's always been part of my work
I I I don't like to write as an expert
another reason I sort of moved off of
food at least for the time being is I
really like writing closer to the
beginning of the learning curve when
everything is still new and exciting and
I and I can bring a sense of wonder to
it
I don't think readers really like being
lectured at by highly experienced
experts I think they'd rather come on a
journey of or an education with you and
so I was outside this world and dipping
my toe in you know first kind of very
tentatively and then you know kind of my
whole foot and then much larger part of
my body but it wasn't a natural
progression for me and it wasn't an easy
progression I mean we'll talk about this
but my you know each of my own
psychedelic journeys that I had for the
book were preceded by a sleepless night
of incredible anxiety where I was just a
ping-pong ball with arguments going back
and forth like are you crazy
you know you're 60 years old
you could have a heart attack up there
on that mountain and this guy's not
gonna call 911 he's worried about his
freedom and and then the other side
saying well come on aren't you curious
about what you might learn and and by
the way you've got a book deadline
coming up you've got to do this and so I
had every every time it was like that it
never got easier and you know I realize
now that was my ego defending itself
against the assault to come and of
course our egos have command of our
rational faculty so they make really
good arguments and mine was definitely
making a good argument to me but thank
God I ignored him could you talk a bit
about what we know or suspect about the
neuroscience behind how these compounds
may have the effects they have and just
as please jump in to correct me at any
point because you were certainly better
versed with with all of this but when
you mentioned four people who who don't
have the background when you mentioned
guided experiences or supervised
environments and the New Yorker piece
I'll just give a little bit of
background for people who may not be
aware that that includes certainly
undergrad options but also includes
universities like Johns Hopkins anyway
NYU you feel that an ever-expanding list
and some very very credible researchers
certainly some who would be considered
the researchers researcher and scientist
what do we know of the science because
these these compounds have been so
mysterious in a sense they've been so
continually used for certainly centuries
if not millennia by different
civilizations you can find totems from
the maz attacks going back thousands of
years and so on what what what new
insights or theories have have caught
your attention in
the scientific realm yeah well the
neuroscience I just have to say is
absolutely fascinating and for me
intellectually that was kind of one of
the most exciting parts of the research
was was learning what were what these
chemicals are teaching us about the mind
in the brain you know there's a famous
quote by stanislav grof who was a czech
emigres psychiatrist who worked with
psychedelics extensively when they were
legal in his practice and he said I
think this was in the early 70s he said
something that a you know sounds
outrageous which is that psychedelics
would be for the study of the mind what
the telescope was for astronomy and what
the microscope was for biology that's a
pretty big claim and and it sounded like
hyperbole to me when I first heard it
but having spent a lot of time in these
labs with these scientists I no longer
think it's impossible that he's right he
may well be right but that said you know
the brain is still very poorly
understood consciousness even more
poorly understood so it's important to
understand that everything I'm about to
tell you is you know hypothesis and some
goes a little further than a hypothesis
but there's still a lot of mysteries the
first one being how does let's say you
you ingest LSD or psilocybin and we know
that it links to a certain kind of brain
receptor the the h2 5ar receptor which
is the same one that's that SSRIs engage
with and that sounds like are we really
understand something but but what
happens downstream of that we don't have
a clue how you get from that active the
activation of those receptors to the
phenomenology the felt experience of of
the drugs so there's there's a lot we
don't understand but one of the most
interesting clues
has come from the work done especially
at Imperial College in London but also
it's now happening at other places in
switzer
at hopkins to to image the brains of
people on psychedelics by image i mean
use fMRIs or some of these other
modalities to see what's going on in the
brain when people are under the
influence and the biggest takeaway from
that work and this is in papers that
robin Carhartt harris an imperial
college has published is that contrary
to what the the neuroscientists expected
which was that the brain would kind of
light up with extra activity because
there was such you know visual and
auditory fireworks going on during the
experience they found that activity in
the brain was actually depressed by
psychedelics particularly in one network
this was a network i had never heard of
before until i started doing this work
and it was only discovered about 15
years ago by a neuroscientist american
neuroscientist at washington university
named marcus ricky'll and that is the
default mode Network
called that because this is kind of
where the brain goes when it's not busy
it's where you go to ruminate worry
daydream and it was discovered when they
were administering fMRI to people and
needed to get a baseline and they would
tell people don't do anything just lie
there and don't you know no tasks and
they would see that oh interesting the
brain is actually quite active when
you're doing nothing and this part of it
is very active this part is a linked set
of structures that include the
prefrontal cortex the posterior
cingulate cortex these are both in the
cortex which is the evolutionarily most
recent part of layer of the brain on the
outside and and then those linked down
into deeper older structures like that
are involved with memory and emotions
and it appears to be a very important
hub the brain is a hierarchical system
and the default mode network kind of
is in charge is a regulator of the whole
and it's involved in a range of
metacognitive functions that includes
self reflection and rumination time
travel that's thinking about the past
and thinking about the future theory of
mind that's the ability to imagine
mental states or attribute mental states
to others and the what is called the
autobiographical memory the
autobiographical self forgive me this is
kind of where we integrate what's
happening to us with the narrative we
have of who we are which is a mix of you
know everything that's happened to us
before are the parts of our biography we
think about and our objectives for the
future and to having a sense of self
that's consistent over time something we
prize even though it's probably
completely illusory that work of
constructing that happens in part of the
parts of the default mode Network so you
could say it's kind of the seat of the
self or the ego to the extent that we
can say that and and how interesting
that this particular network important
as it is gets goes offline or at least
has activity diminished and and this is
really interesting the more precipitous
the drop in activity in the default mode
Network the more likely someone is
liable to report that they experienced
ego dissolution that that experience
that's common on a high dose of
psychedelics that can either be
terrifying or absolutely ecstatic of
having your sense of self disappear or
melt or dissolve and which is then
followed by this merging with you know
the larger world the nature the universe
other people and so that seems to be
involved with the you know diminution of
activity in this in this particular
network so that gives us a window into
the self and into spiritual experience
because that experience would be going
to Salou
feels to people like a mystical
experience feels like it's very
spiritual this sense of you know
transcending this bag of bones we are
and and and actually connect with with
larger entities and it's that experience
to that may make it easier to die in
that ego dissolution is a kind of
rehearsal for death giving up yourself
and and then seeing and this was for me
the most incredible thing was that your
ego could die but you still perceive you
there's still a consciousness another
consciousness and and I think that
that's enormous ly comforting to two
people
so anyway from a neuroscientific point
of view this is a really interesting
insight and psychedelics gave it to us
there two other things I want to say
about it that's it's also even more
interesting one is that when they when
other researchers at Yale started
scanning the brains of really
experienced meditators you know people
with 10,000 hours who really know how to
how to meditate their scans look very
similar to the people on psychedelics on
suicide them that they to that
meditation is another way to quiet the
default mode Network and my guess is
there's several others too my guess is
it's quieted when you're you know when
you fast you know when you're on a
Vision Quest when you go into sensory
deprivation my guess is that all these
powerful experiences may well involve
alternate modalities for shutting off or
quieting the default mode Network so
that's a big takeaway and I think will
be significant in the future the other
point I want to make about that and the
neuroscience is that also coming out of
Robin Carhartt Harris's lab was they
they mapped connections they call it the
connectome in the in the human brain and
that changes during the experience when
you turn off the default mode Network
which which Robin refers to as the
orchestra conductor
or corporate executive or capital city
of the brainy as all these wonderful
metaphors when that goes offline other
parts of the brain and other networks
that don't ordinarily talk to each other
strike up conversations and if you look
at this image which is reprinted in my
book actually they did it in color in
the middle of the book I didn't even
know they could do this toward the end
of the book you see that what had been
this this set of principle you know main
thoroughfares connecting different
networks in the brain suddenly you get
lots of little roads new connections
myriad new connections get established
basically because probably because the
default mode network is not requiring
everybody come through that hub and so
you have for example perhaps emotion
center is talking directly to your
visual cortex which lo and behold could
allow you to see things your your
feeling you know could could result in
loosen ations those new connections may
and now I'm being speculative may
manifest as new perspectives new ideas
new memes new metaphors but the point is
that by temporarily you know disrupting
the order of the brain a new order forms
and that order may have incredible value
at either the level of mental health and
psychology or at the level of creativity
and that's what we need to get into
right now what what happens with those
new connections do they endure or not
and are there ways to help them endure
longer the visualization that you
mentioned is so the difference is so
pronounced and it's really something to
behold so I certainly encourage people
to just take a moment to soak the image
in when they have a chance to look at it
and it's not hard to find online - it's
not hard to find online and what I
wanted to I mean certainly these
compounds are not panaceas they don't
fix everything and and they do have
risks I mean I think we should talk
about though we're absolutely going to
talk about the risks but before we get
too
that I wanted to go back to the studies
that have been done and to ask you what
studies have most perhaps shocked you or
surprised you or have stuck with you and
just for purposes of supposed sharing on
my side the studies are really
wide-ranging than many studies had been
performed in the specific well I'm not
sure he's in early 60s but the even
looking at the more recent studies
related to smoking cessation or
different forms of addiction certainly
end-of-life anxiety a treatment
resistant depression dear number
characteristics that have been really
surprising to me when looking at the
results but I'd be curious to hear if
there any related to the magnitude
persistence or anything of effects that
have been particularly memorable for you
yeah yeah well I mean the first one that
was really memorable to me was the first
one I read and this was a 2006 study by
done at Johns Hopkins in the lab of
Roland Griffiths who I believe you know
pretty well I didn't this was a kind of
wild study because it didn't purport to
have any practical utility at all it
wasn't it had nothing to do with health
or healing people it was really an
attempt to see if psilocybin could be
used to occasion that's the verb they
use to occasion profound mystical
experiences in people and the title of
this paper is kind of hilarious you know
high dose of psilocybin can occasion
profound mystical experiences in people
that are have you know lasting value or
something like that I don't have it
quite right but it's it just stood out
as weight scientists do this that's
pretty cool and what's a mystical
experience doing in a scientific
experiment but it in a way this was the
predicate of all the research to come in
this in this Renaissance that's going on
because they had found first they had
proven that you could safely administer
these drugs in
environment and that with a very high
percentage you could induce this kind of
experience that people would report as
one of the three two or three most
meaningful experiences in their lives
comparable to the birth of a child or
the death of a parent the fact that you
could induce such an experience in a
laboratory reliably with a mushroom
well that that kind of blew my mind and
and I talked I interviewed many people
in that trial and it was really
interesting to hear their experience
these are these are so-called healthy
normals so they didn't have a pathology
they weren't dying and they were kind of
spiritually inclined that was definitely
you know it seemed to me a common
denominator of the people of the
volunteers but that that this drug would
create an experience that was
indistinguishable from mystical
experiences as we have them in the
literature as they were recorded by the
great mystics of of all time
and and all the writers who talked about
mystical experience from you know
Whitman to Emerson to to Tennyson so I
thought that was a really cool study and
the testimony of the people in it was
very interesting it was also interesting
that you know follow-up they crunched
that data very carefully and they
discovered that a significant Elyse
ignition person tidge of people who had
had these psilocybin experiences had
actually had changes in their
personality that were enduring
psychologists divided personality up
into five traits and I'm not gonna
remember them all but it's things like
conscientiousness neuroticism
extraversion openness and I forget the
fifth but openness which correlates with
you know tolerance for other people's
points of view ability to take in lots
of surprising information creativity
actually was increased a statistically
significant increase in openness
and that's it's very rare that
personality changes in adults at all and
the idea that a mushroom could induce
such a change was really striking now
this has yet to be reproduced this
particular result but whether there are
lasting changes in personality of people
who take psychedelics I think is a
really rich topic to explore and and and
definitely deserve more work the the
smoking study you alluded to I thought
was also fascinating you know here you
have one of the hardest of all habits to
kick and eighty percent of people who
went through this process which involved
two or three psychedelic trips on
psilocybin and some cognitive behavioral
therapy in between eighty percent were
confirmed abstinent had we're not
smoking at the six-month mark and that
number fell to I think it was sixty
seven percent after a year this is a
small pilot study open-label which means
everybody knew they were getting
psilocybin nobody got a placebo but
that's that's pretty impressive and in
fact sixty-seven percent success after a
year is better than anything else that's
out there so this study needs to be
replicated and yes nothing happening
yeah sorry to interrupt but also as I
understand it it's not a marginal
difference in efficacy compared to the
standard of care for looking at
alternative treatments I mean the the
Delta at least with this preliminary
study as you mentioned open labels
something I mean I have somebody out
there on the Internet can certainly
correct me but I want to say this but
perhaps the alternative sort of option
be more traditionally speaking be
somewhere in the 20s and in terms of
efficacy at the six-month mark looking
at absence rates I could be I could be
that there's a drug people who use
called chantix that I've seen advertised
on television I think that does a little
better than that twenty percent mark but
you know the patch is not that
successful and so it's a big deal
but was what was also noteworthy to me
about that particular stuff
he was talking to the people in the
study and and I would ask them you know
so why did this make it any easier to
quit smoking I mean doesn't seem to have
anything to do with smoking and they
would describe an experience that put
their life and their behavior in such a
radically new context and they would say
that you know they would say these
incredibly banal things they'd say like
I realized my breath is precious and
that there's no life without breath and
it's really stupid to to damage your
breath and I'm like duh didn't you know
that already and and they didn't know it
in an intellectual way but I think one
of the the real hallmarks of psychedelic
experience is that things you think you
know but but really only exists on the
very top of consciousness subtly set
down roots deep in your subconscious and
they become these you know convictions
absolute rock-solid convictions that you
believe in a way you've never believed
anything before and that I think allows
people to kind of you know put flesh on
some platitude like smoking is bad for
you
and and killing herself is stupid
suddenly you feel it at a much deeper
level and so I was struck by that and in
fact Matt Johnson who was the
psychologist that at Hopkins who
directed this study he calls them dumb
moments do you know that is that people
have a lot of moments but they're
transformative and that is you know if
you've ever had a psychedelic experience
there is that weird bleeding from
banality into profundity and back again
that happens and that definitely seems
to go on so so one of the the ways one
of the psychological mechanisms that may
be at work is this ability to reinforce
an idea that we all already know or we
should know better and make it powerful
enough to actually guide our behavior
what are some of the applet potential
applications or
current applications in a scientific
environment or elsewhere that are most
interesting to you
I'm personally tracking potential use of
psychedelics which is certainly already
in motion outside the US hopefully will
be researched more in the US but as it
would apply to say opiate addiction yeah
really problems of epidemic proportions
are there are there any particular
applications that you're paying
attention to yeah well I you know first
of all it's really important to
understand that these that this research
comes along at a critical moment our
mental health care system is badly
broken you know if you compare mental
health treatment to any other branch of
medicine mental health care fails
abysmally I mean it has not extended
lifespan lowered mortality it hasn't
done what you know work on cancer work
on the heart work on you know virtually
other an infectious disease it's
remarkable what a pathetic track record
it has and with all the you know use of
SSRIs in the culture and shrinks you
know which here in Berkeley they're you
know every other persons a shrink the
fact is that rates of depression are
soaring rates of suicide are rising
dramatically and addiction too is
rampant and so there's a real crisis
here and there hasn't been any real
innovation in mental health care since I
would say 1990 or so with the
introduction of the SSRIs the
antidepressants that work on the
serotonin system so I'm particularly
interested as you are in the work on
addiction I think that that's very
promising and it's an area where we
don't have a lot in the pipeline
ibogaine is a another psychedelic comes
from a root of a tree in Africa and it
has been shown in you know still very
preliminary research to be useful with
opiate addiction
partly because it blunts the the
withdrawal symptoms at the same time it
helps you get off the drugs but it's a
it's a very heavy and risky psychedelic
and it lasts for a very long time there
are clinics in Mexico that are
administering it to opiate addiction but
there is work planned to look at
psilocybin and opiate addiction
psilocybin and alcohol addiction is is
underway right now in a large study at
NYU that I think bears bears close
watching and then there's all the work
that's about to happen about psilocybin
and depression treatment resistant
depression is the subject of study in
Europe coming up and that's people whose
depression has not responded to to other
forms of treatment so a particularly
needy group of people and then a study
in this country of major depression and
that will be getting underway this year
I think if these drugs can can really
make a dent in those indications it
would be it would be enormous it would
just be you know and the depression
studies very interesting how that came
about
the researchers you know had looked at
depression in their population of cancer
patients they were they were dealing
with both depression and anxiety and the
results of those studies found that in
roughly 80% of the cases the patient the
volunteers had had statistically
significant reductions in symptoms of
depression and anxiety so a pretty big
deal a very strong treatment effect much
stronger by the way than the treatment
effect that got SSRIs of group but when
they went to the FDA seeking permission
to do a phase 3 trial and cancer
patients
the FDA regulators said to them we've
got a much bigger problem
a much larger population of people
struggling with depression and there's a
strong signal here that this that these
drugs may help with depression so we
want you to study that
and part of the reason they did that is
they well recognize that there's not a
lot of drugs in the pipeline and the
SSRIs are you know losing their
effectiveness which was never too great
to begin with we're learning you know
that SSRIs do perform slightly better
than placebos and their effect appears
to fade over time and also people hate
being on them because of the side
effects so you mentioned something that
may surprise people and that is FDA
support in this case and certainly we
don't we we don't necessarily have to
get into MDMA but MDMA was granted
breakthrough therapy designation - which
is remarkable expedite the process of
phase 3 trials for PTSD and that seems
that odd with something that came up
earlier which was this moral panic after
the psychedelic 60s and the Controlled
Substances Act and the current legal
status of these drugs so what has
changed I mean you would think if we if
we look at the mystical experiences and
the peace that people feel or the
oneness the timelessness the
ineffability one would be inclined to
think hey if you're trying to treat
alcohols and with that you're just gonna
give them a state they want to return to
over and over again yeah well that's a
good question I think it's important to
understand that psychedelics are not the
classical psychedelics are not addictive
so it's not like you're giving them
another drug that they're gonna get
hooked on you know in the classic drug
addiction experiments where you give a
primate you know I'm sorry you give a
rat or a mouse
two levers in the cage and one has food
and one has cocaine or heroin you know
they'll keep pressing the cocaine or
heroin till they die over and they'll
prefer it over food if you make one of
those levers give them access to LSD
they'll press it once and never again
they don't want to go there and you know
if you use these drugs
your first thought on the conclusion of
the experience is not and I got to do
that again it takes months to recover
and I don't mean recover but it takes
months to process everything that
happened and it was so it's so
disruptive and and so extreme and
experienced that your first thought is
not one where where can I get my next
hit so there's that but yeah I mean it's
a weird idea you know back in the 50s
one of the the really interesting
stories that that you find if you dig
into the research deep enough and the
fifties period is fascinating is that
Bill W the the founder of Alcoholics
Anonymous first he got sober after he
had been administered a psychedelic or a
drug that some people call a psychedelic
called belladonna in in the 30s and then
in the 50s he got involved with LSD
therapy in LA and he thought that LSD
might be able to help alcoholics and he
and he went to the board which he was on
of AAA and said look LSD we should
really take a look at it maybe we want
to incorporate it in the program and his
fellow board members are like are you
crazy I mean that's gonna that's gonna
ruin our brand that's gonna you know
confuse people so there is a kind of
fundamental sense that it seems weird to
treat a drug with another drug but these
drugs are so substantially different and
they appear to be effective in treating
at least some kinds of addictions that
it would be shameful for us not to do
the research and explore it the kinds of
risks that are present in it I mean
there are risk but addiction is not one
of them if that's the case why have
these why if these compounds been so
difficult to research why are they not
freely available I mean what happened
that took them off the table for so long
well I mean the 60s happened you know
the there's a there's a chapter in the
book right I look at the sort of rise in
quick fall of psychedelics during the
60s and it's a really fascinating
episode and there it's full of
cautionary
details you know it's funny I would ask
I would ask researchers I was
interviewing so what happened why was
there such a backlash against
psychedelics that that research was
which closed down you know that never
happens that you have a promising field
of research and suddenly scientists feel
they can't do it anymore and they're
told to stop I mean this is you know
this is kind of dark Aegis stuff and in
in and to a man and they are mostly men
I'm afraid they will say well it's too
simple to blame Timothy Leary and then
they'll go on to blame Timothy here and
he does have a very important role in
this and basically Leary you know
started studying psilocybin and then LSD
at Harvard from 1960 to 1963 and keep in
mind the drugs were legal then and but
he got impatient with with research with
science pretty early on and he decided
well you can't really do a controlled
study of psychedelics so why bother and
he started studying psychedelics in a
net what he called a naturalistic
environment which meant that you know
his living room and and as happens to
some psychedelic researchers they lose
interest in treating individuals and
acquire an interest in treating the
whole of the culture because they start
seeing that you know retailing these
things is too slow when they're so
promising and they could actually save
us from civilizational collapse and you
have this exuberance irrational
exuberance I would add that seems to
come up in the minds of some people who
work with these compounds and and it's
an occupational hazard I would argue and
and the current generation of
researchers are guarding against it but
take them out for a drink and you know
they'll come around to that place the
value of these the value of these
compounds for the whole civilization
which is interesting and they may well
be right but it's it's a dangerous way
to talk I think and so
something else was going on in the 60s
and that was that these drugs were used
by the on by teenagers and people in
their 20s and it created a generate what
was called a generation gap and a very
unusual splitting of the cultures and
values of two generations these drugs
were doing something very unusual to
that historical moment and something
that will never happen again let me
explain what I mean
LSD a high dose psilocybin or LSD trip
is a kind of rite of passage a searing
rite of passage you feel like you you
you went in one person and you came out
another person and it did this for the
young at that point that's who used
these drugs not too many older people
use them and normally a rite of passage
knits a culture together it's organized
by the by the elders who set up the bar
whatever it is whether it's a Bar
Mitzvah or a Vision Quest or whatever it
is and the youth the adolescents pass
through that process and then land in
the country of the adults and that's how
you grow up here was this really freaky
rite of passage that was taking young
people and dumping them in a country of
the mind that adults knew nothing about
and I think it really drove a wedge in
the culture and it's no accident that
you had this unusual divergence of youth
culture in both in terms of everything
from politics dress
music diet sexual mores morality was
different than adults and and that was
very destabilizing for the culture and
and you know not surprisingly the elders
reacted with with fear and panic and
tried to put it into this
you know Richard Nixon called Timothy
Leary who was already at kind of a
washed-up psychology professor called
him the most dangerous man in America
that's astounding but you know he
probably really believed it he believed
these drugs were we're keeping men from
you know going to fight in Vietnam one
of the things that happens is that you
you you know these drugs make you raise
questions about the authority structure
that you live in and that was certainly
happening so they were very
destabilizing and there was a backlash
whether Timothy Leary was solely
responsible for that that that seems
unfair I mean he he he was definitely
the East Coast person most responsible
for it but remember on the West Coast
you had Ken Kesey the writer who is
turning on thousands of people in his
acid tests and is you know is also a
psychedelic evangelist and he was turned
on by the CIA inadvertently you know
they were they were testing their LSD
and they were paying people 50 bucks to
go to the VA hospital and in the middle
of Parker Palo Alto and and and and have
a dose and they turned on the wrong guy
yeah this story is so outrageous
I had never I'd never been exposed to
the details in your book and it's just
if someone were to write a novel with
that as the plot I mean they'd have to
be like Haruki Murakami or something
it's so surreal yeah and the idea that
the that the 60 is what we call the 60s
might have been a CIA my mind-control
experiment gone horribly good or bad
yeah is is mind-blowing so I think the
drugs would have found their way into
the counterculture one way or the other
there were you know there were other
roots
besides Timothy Leary even though he was
pushing really hard to make this happen
but that led to a backlash and you had
the government coming down hard on it
the media who had been oh and this was
one of the real surprises in researching
the book incredibly booster ish about
psychedelics
time-life which was the most one of the
most important media empires in the
country controlled by henry luce they
were actively promoting psychedelics up
until up till 1965 henry luce loved them
he and his wife had been treated
successfully he published Gordon
Watson's
first account of a magic mushroom
experience in Mexico in the 1950s and in
fact he insisted that all coverage of
psychedelics come to his desk so he can
make sure it didn't have anything
negative in it so so we the culture
undergoes a radical 180 around 1965 and
that leads to the closing off of
research so that begs the question could
it happen again
I don't think it could happen quite that
way and the reason it couldn't and for
this idea i credit rick doblin if he's
right and i know but he might you might
be wrong but rick doblin is the head of
maps the multidisciplinary association
of psychedelic studies thinks that the
culture has changed too much that we've
absorbed so many innovations of the 60s
and that the people now in charge
many of them have tripped psychedelics
are not so strange to them and that's
why you have you know really some
establishment voices in the psychiatric
establishment people like Paul summer
grad and Jeffrey Lieberman both past
presidents of the American Psychiatric
Association have talked about their own
use of psychedelics and the role it
played in their intellectual development
no doubt some of these regulators at the
FDA have you know first-person
experience of psychedelics so they're
not terrified of them in quite the way
our parents were my parents were in the
in the 60s and and I think there's some
comfort in that for people doing this
research that it's unlikely to happen
that way could it happen another way yes
I mean let's say someone is someone dies
in this research or there is you know
some some adverse you know events or
there are suicides associated with
psychedelics which have happened in the
past and could happen again the the
cultural climate could change you know
we also have Jeffrey Sessions is the is
the Attorney General and he's you know
he's not content he's not happy with
states legalizing cannabis how's he
gonna feel what the FDA comes forward
and approves psychedelics it's not
guaranteed that they'll be against it I
mean there's another lens you could take
to this there are D regulators and
that's essentially what we're talking
about right is deregulating a
pharmaceutical catch-up in for one
second I'm so curious do you not think
there would be incredible backlash if
sessions or someone else were to come
out against Phase three trials that are
specifically dealing with say victims of
sexual assault from DSD war veterans
returning with pronounced trauma and
limbs blown off I mean it seems to be
such a bipartisan issue and in
everyone's best interest there would
seem to be some political risk in trying
to stop these types of studies maybe
maybe I'm not absolutely right and you
and your example is the good example I
mean the the the MDMA work for PTSD I
mean this is you know is there a more
sympathetic population that you could
possibly be helping and in the same way
you know the whole system finally was
moved to make it easier to have access
to AIDS drugs because there was nothing
else that could help I think that yes I
think there would be a penalty and I
don't think it's an accident it's not a
right-left issue when you start talking
about the military and cops
you know Rebecca Mercer has donated to
to this to research to psychedelic
research specifically I think with the
PTSD work Steve Bannon has spoken out in
favor of it so and Peter Thiel is is an
investor in
in psychedelic medicine so it's it isn't
necessarily the case that it's regarded
as this left-wing thing even though it
has these culture countercultural
you know colorations so I don't think
it's simple at all but we'll see we'll
see you know if the FDA looks at these
phase three results and this is a couple
years down the road and says that yes
these drugs should be approved and
doctors should be able to prescribe them
the DEA the Drug Enforcement
Administration which is part of the
Justice Department then has to
reschedule them scheduling drugs is a
political determination finally and they
have DEA is sometimes been immune to
scientific information but I think it
would be you know it would be an
interesting moment I'm not sure how it
would come out but I think that this
work with dealing with post-traumatic
stress disorder and dealing with the so
called existential distress of cancer
patients wins the sympathy of the public
especially when you're doing it with a
drug that where the risk profile is is
really not very bad so we'll see I think
it's a big question you know the idea
that there's any kind of logical
response on the part of the Trump
administration to anything you know how
that has to be factored into so that you
mentioned risks earlier I think we
should talk about that I mean what what
is the risk profile right what are the
risks to these compounds what's the you
know the ld50 if we have a thousand
people in a room what's the dose it
takes to kill 500 of them well there's
there's no known lethal dose of
psilocybin or LSD that's you know if it
kills you it's not going to be because
it's toxic they're not toxic there I
mean remarkably few molecules have this
profound effect and they don't stay in
your body that long so from a toxicity
point of view they're remarkably safe
drugs I think that the risks come are
more psychological in origin they are in
credibly disruptive they disarm your
usual defenses and defenses you know can
be very helpful as well as hurtful and
some people without their defenses get
into real trouble people do foolish
things on psychedelics people take them
carelessly and they you know walk into
traffic
they you know they step off of buildings
so I think and then there is a small
subgroup of people at risk for serious
mental illness things like schizophrenia
for whom psychedelics can be the trigger
and push people into that first
psychotic break
and I think that that happened you know
wasn't so uncommon with people in their
early 20s using these drugs and that
happens to be the age where this tends
to happen would it happen without the
psychedelics probably another trauma
would have set it off if not the
psychedelics but but it does happen and
I think that one of the reasons that
there have not been any adverse events
any serious adverse events in the
thousand volunteers that have been you
know have been dosed in the modern era
of research is that they're screening
very carefully anybody who's got mental
illness and their family is not eligible
and so you know that's kind of a luxury
of doing small trials you can be very
picky about who you give the drug to and
that's one of the reasons that phase
three may not be quite as dramatic and
it's in its you know success as as Phase
two has been so I think that there are
people who should not take these drugs
and and it's people at some
psychological risk that said it's it's
worth pointing out there's a story I
tell in the book that very often doctors
who in the 60s especially who weren't
familiar with psychedelics and there and
and and the phenomenology of them
mistook panic attacks simple panic
attacks which are common on the drugs
for psychotic break
and there's a great story that Andy
Wilde told me dr. Andrew Weil about
after he got out of medical school in in
1968 he hustled out to San Francisco and
volunteered at the Haight Ashbury free
clinic and they were seeing lots of bad
trips and people would come in and they
thought they were going mad that they
were gonna die and and you know we
shouldn't minimize how bad a bad trip
can be it's it's a it's a terrifying
experience and that that too is it is a
risk even if it is just a panic attack
but Andy had had a lot of experience
with psychedelics himself and he saw
these this these symptoms for what they
were and what he would do is he'd come
into the little cubicle with his white
coat and a stethoscope and his clipboard
and he'd ask a few questions and the one
he decided the person was not really
psychotic but was just freaking out he
would go to that he would say excuse me
but there's someone in real trouble in
the next cubicle and all at once these
people were like wow there's someone
more [ __ ] up than I am and they would
feel so much better and their symptoms
would pass so he understood that you
could manipulate the experience which is
of course what the guides understand to
and and rescue someone from what had
been a pretty horrifying episode so you
know how many psychotic breaks were
there in the 60s you know you hear you
know that there were you know the Holly
the emergency rooms were for a period
were you know full of people on bad LSD
trips and maybe that's true but what was
that actually it may have just been a
bad trip and bad trips are first they
can be averted with good guiding and
second they can actually be very useful
to people if they're properly analyzed
and I think the at least you know the
way that I've started to think about
this reading your book and becoming
involved with the research is that maybe
a more useful delineation is safe and
unsafe trip in the sense the difficulty
that does not necessarily translate to
long term negative outcomes in some
to the contrary they're very much the
contrary yeah and I I want to pause for
just a second here to make it an appeal
if there are regulators lawmakers
listening and that is that speaking is
someone who I assure you is not dancing
around the playa and a thong at Burning
Man calling himself a shaman that's not
my dick but conversely has looked at
mental illness and friends suicide and
friends in high school and college have
friends with say eating disorders of 20
30 years that have been not just
mitigated but resolved to fit I can't
say definitively of course but for years
now
after say one two three controlled
sessions looking at the risk profile of
these drugs there are risks to be sure
but the the potential benefit the the
the cost effectiveness and the
pronounced favorable risk profile is
really remarkable I mean beyond just
about anything I've seen not a panacea
but with some very promising indications
that that make it at the very least
worth researching in depth and I don't
want to sound too much like
proselytizing but yeah if you look at
say you know if there are drugs looking
at my pharmacogenomics if I were to take
them I could have a fatal response right
there which are common common common
drugs if you take grapefruit juice which
can certainly change the metabolism of
many drugs you can have horrible side
effects and if you look at if you were
to print out let's just say
hypothetically years from now you have
the psilocybin available and you go to
Walgreens to pick up your psilocybin and
maybe it's only available through a
therapist or a doctor who's going to be
supervising a session but nonetheless
let's imagine this is an exercise and
you pick up your your little white bag
with the pharmacists directions and
warnings on the side compared to just
about
anything else to date that I would have
routinely consumed the profile of
something like a psilocybin would be
very very favorable for a lot of things
and of course we're operating from a
place of incomplete information just
because the research has been so stymied
but the the early indicators seem to be
really promising so I would just say
from from the standpoint of regulators
not calling it the some of the Golden
Goose but this some of these compounds
have the potential to transform how
increasingly problematic often fatal
problems in mental health and elsewhere
are treated so it's you know I agree
with you entirely and I think that yes
as with any drug you've got to compare
it with other drugs and that they all
have risks and we put up with a certain
amount of risk to get the benefit and
that the risks in this case certainly at
the biological level are our minor
compared to drugs we take routinely that
even over-the-counter drugs that are
more toxic then then psychedelics as far
as we know so I think that's definitely
worth keeping in mind you know because
these drugs are illicit they're
surrounded by this penumbra of fear
that's a good word no man it's and we
need to like look at them with a very
kind of cool objective lens which is
hard to do you know David Nutt who's a
very well-known psychopharmacologist in
England who's involved with the the
research it's in his lab that Robin
Carhartt Harris works he did a very
interesting analysis of a bunch of drugs
and he would compare them not even to
themselves but to other kinds of risky
behavior and he got in really hot water
not only did he say that alcohol is more
toxic than LSD which got him fired he
was working for the government as there
at the Labor Government's drugs advisor
but then he said riding a horse is more
dangerous than taking MDMA now we never
put those two things together but you
know why don't we have this conversation
about I'm just I'm just seeing the
commercial like this the 30-second spot
safer than riding a horse
so you know I think we have to I think
we're really nuts I mean in general you
know any behavioral economist I'm sure
you've had them on the show will tell
you that we're we're nuts about risk and
and really irrational and how we
confront it so it's important understand
that there are risks there mostly
psychological people can have very
painful experiences but in terms of
poisoning your body you could do a lot
worse and one of the portions in your
book that really caught my attention and
got me excited was related to the
default mode Network and I'm probably
gonna butcher this paraphrasing so I
want you to correct me but but the it
was the observation that perhaps some of
these conditions that a lay person is
prone to thinking of as separate whether
that's chronic anxiety chronic
depression OCD eating disorders that
they may not in fact be as separate as
yeah as we think and I want to say that
dr. Tom Insel may have commented on this
former head of the National Institute on
or mental health could you could you
just elaborate on that because this it's
so exciting to me for for many reasons
that I want to do justice so could you
yeah I'm glad you brought that up
because it's one of the most exciting
things in the book I think and I talked
about this idea that we may be close to
or see a path to developing what I call
the grand unified theory of mental
illness or at least a set of a big set
of mental illnesses that include
depression anxiety addiction and
obsession and one of the questions I
asked and so when I interviewed him was
and this is you know one of the things I
was skeptical about that it seems kind
of implausible to me that one drug or
one you know category of drugs like
psychedelics should work on so many
different indications isn't that a
little too good to be true isn't that
you know aren't you talking panacea and
he said well what makes you think those
indications are so different those
illnesses are so different and he said
the distinctions been
between depression anxiety obsession and
addiction are actually there's a lot of
bleeding over from one to another and
that that the the names that we give
them are really an artifact of the of
the insurance industry and the DSM you
know the diagnostic manual we have to
assign a number to every diagnosis and
so we tend to separate things and but
he's kind of more of a lumper and he and
he suggests that you know these could be
very similar phenomenon and that you
know one way another psychiatrist put it
is is you know depression is is kind of
regret about the past and anxiety is
regret about the future it's like oh
that's really interesting they are you
know the real difference between
depression and anxiety is tense isn't it
and so when you when you step back to
another level and you look at the
mechanisms that may be at work here you
begin to see how these illnesses may be
very similar how do I mean well if you
look at again go back to Robin Carhartt
Harris's work on the default mode
Network his premise he wrote another
really interesting paper I strongly
anyone who has an appetite for a little
neuroscience should check out this paper
it's called the entropic brain and you
should put it on your website I can't
say yeah I'll put it not on it and and
there he his his idea is that the brain
as it is as we know a very complex
system and it has an order an emergent
order that is to some extent enforced or
regulated by the default mode Network
and the ego is the felt you know version
of that and the egos job is to kind of
patrol the boundaries all right it's the
cop on patrol and it's patrolling the
boundary between you and the other you
know
things that aren't you and you and your
unconscious and and the system you know
has this kind of structural order but in
many people that order gets overly rigid
and that brains function along a
spectrum from entropy to rigidity and on
the entropy end you have serious
psychological ailments like
schizophrenia and you also but you also
have childhood consciousness which is
very chaotic and very psychedelic in
many ways and and then on the other end
of the spectrum you get to these
illnesses characterized by too much
order essentially and that's depression
and obsession and addiction and these
are essentially ailments where people
get stuck in repetitive loops that these
deep grooves of thought and behavior are
which are enforced by an ego that's
become almost punishing you know you
know too authoritarian and so these
brains are kind of locked and these
other brains you know are just way loose
and there's a there's a place you want
to be in the middle there there's a
point of criticality really where you
have enough entropy but also enough
order and that we go wrong when we when
we get too far to one end to the other
that's his theory anyway it's it's
speculative but but but has a lot of
explanatory power and basically he
thinks that psychedelics work by
increasing the amount of entropy in the
brain and that entropy up to a point is
a very positive thing and that it is the
lack of entropy that that traps people
in these very rigid patterns of thought
and behavior and that essentially the
LSD or the psilocybin lubricates
cognition it can go too far and leads to
magical thinking which is also on too
much entropy side but it also can help
break people out of those habits so
there you begin to see the the
outlines of a you a grand unified theory
of mental illness that and that's that's
really exciting stuff it it makes me
think of it's so so exciting because
it's it's it's stuffed offers this
tantalizing possibility that you could
address many many different separately
labeled conditions mm-hmm in a similar
way and I'm not going to name names but
I was speaking with a researcher in this
field very well published scientist and
the the analogy that he use and I'm
gonna modify it a little bit but he said
that because my question to him was what
what is it what is a plausible
explanation for why these some of these
compounds seem to have this long-term
reorganizing effect because the the the
half-life of the drug so to speak is not
months long so what the hell happens
where these people in some cases have
this persistence of personality change
where they have more empathy a year
later two years later what on earth can
explain that and the picture he painted
because the the mechanisms are still so
poorly understood was well you can
imagine if you're on a on a ski mountain
no I know who you're talking about
after a few hours you have all these
worn ruts and it becomes more and more
likely that people are going to use the
the ruts that have been laid down but if
there's yeah you can't get out of them
right yeah your sled or your skis keeps
tending back into them and writing your
yes and so it but if you suddenly have
five feet of fresh powder whatever three
feet it doesn't really matter and then
you get up to the top of the lift you
all of a sudden have to buy almost by
definition choose a new path you're at
least given the flexibility to choose
your new route and but taken too far
it's just like being stuck in a blizzard
right well that's not gonna that's my
own addition not terribly original but
yet but it's I really need to meet Robin
at some point but I haven't you - yeah
he's he's a brilliant guy and I think he
will be recognized as a really important
or a scientist he's just got a very
unusual mind because he can do the hard
science but he's also trained as a
psychoanalyst he's actually a Freudian
very
very interesting mix of he got into this
because he wanted to show the
psychological the the neuro scientific
basis for Freudian ideas like repression
and and so yeah he's a he's a really
interesting guy
that I think that that snow metaphor is
really powerful we don't understand the
mechanism what exactly is filling those
ruts you know in a way that lasts I mean
I think though it may go back to that
image of you know creating some new
linkages in the brain some new pathways
and basically you know that's what
learning is it's a pathway in the brain
and then you reinforce it by repetition
so that if you have had such a linkage
on an experience and you simply think
about it a lot and I've certainly done
this in my own experiences it reinforces
it you can use meditation to reinforce
it you can just merely just replay it in
your head and and in time you're
creating a more and more resilient
linkage and and that's why I think that
the integration period after the session
is so important you know in in all the
both underground and above-ground guided
sessions there are three stages that you
know they prepare you for it they they
guide you they sit with you while you're
having the experience and then you
always come back the next day and this
is probably the most important part to
figure out what the hell was that all
about
and it's often hard to know and and many
of us take a you know a big psychedelic
experience and we put it in this box
called weird drug experience and we put
it away on the shelf because we don't
know what to do with it and no one's
gonna help us but at the integration the
guide will will have you talk out your
experience tell the narrative and then
we'll kind of underscore certain ideas
and I remember well some times I had
when I when I had good guiding that they
would buy by emphasizing one particular
theme or insider image basically make
that linkage much stronger than it would
have been and
became the thing that I thought about
the most and and then was and acquired a
certain kind of power in my mind so so I
think that there's a lot more to be done
with figuring out how to take elements
from the experience and and kind of
reify them and make them more real and
more lasting Michael this seems like a
good time to get into those personal
experiences and I don't know where to
start but I thought since you mentioned
themes images insights we could use that
as a jumping off point and you could
start wherever you'd like to start
really but I would be very curious to
hear you describe any of your
experiences that that ended up being
very meaningful for you sure yeah you
know it's funny I said earlier I
approached the my psychedelic journeys
with a lot of trepidation and and I
approached the writing of them with a
lot of trepidation all after the fact
because I you know I didn't know that I
could it's a real literary challenge if
you think about how many trip reports
you've read that were any good you know
you can count them on one hand and so
that was the kind of Everest I kept
moving toward as I was going through the
book is like oh my god I'm gonna have to
explain these experiences in the event
it turned out to be great fun to write
about I I really enjoyed writing about
it it was it was a challenge but of the
best of the best sort I had just to give
you the landscape of it
I had experiences with LSD these are
guided experiences with LSD psilocybin
five Meo DMT and which is a pretty
obscure psychedelic that's made from the
well that is the smoked venom of the
Sonoran Desert toad yes somebody figured
that out and then ayahuasca a couple
ayahuasca circles I would say that for
me the most useful insightful experience
was a guided psilocybin journey where I
was trying to approximate the dosage
being used in the
in the above-ground trials I think I was
a little shy of that and I worked with a
wonderful guide a woman on the East
Coast and what can I say about this
experience what was really important
about this experience was that I
experienced ego dissolution for the
first time I had read a lot about it
non-dual consciousness and and I was
curious to have such an experience and
also you know very nervous about it
just to plus art interjects so non-dual
meaning what that means that you'll no
longer this the observer yeah normally
you know we're the subject we're the
perceiving subject and everything else
is the object of our perceptions right
and we have this kind of split and that
kind of defines our consciousness to a
large extent and it's a rather self
selfish way of looking at things but
that's how most of us look and probably
many animals look at things that way too
although we don't have much report and
but that non-dual consciousness is where
that sense of separation breaks down
either because they're other subjects
you're aware of you know I mean I've had
an experience where the plants were I
realized they had a subjectivity too and
they were they were looking back at me
in a sense and that that also tends to
break down Dule the sense of duality
that that we go through life with so so
this happened you know this wasn't
always a pleasant experience i I took
the mushroom it was a very large
mushroom that I ate with some chocolate
and it was a she she was kind of more in
the shamanic style of guides as many
underground guides are it really is you
have a sense of ceremony more than you
do in the above-ground trials and
initially one of the problems I've had
with the underground guides is their
musical taste which is just horrible
very often I mean to me it's it's the
kind of music that's fine if you're
getting a really high-quality massage at
a you know a top resort
but for a psychological experience it
seems a little wanting and so she put on
this piece of of new-age claptrap and
and it immediately put me in and I
thought it was electronica I thought
it's electronic music it turned out not
to be but and I and I immediately put me
in this space of a computer or video
game I was in a world that had been
generated by computers and and it was
dark and very sleek it wasn't scary but
it was claustrophobic and and just I
wanted to be outside so there I was in
this in this dystopian video game going
along and seeing you know all these
digitally created things and you know I
can imagine somebody who would enjoy
this space but it wasn't my space and
and I asked her to change the music and
it got a little better and and as the
experience moved on I started to get a
little anxious that oh my god I'm
trapped in computer world how can I get
out of here and but I remembered my
flight instructions that's a word used
at Hopkins for to describe what you're
told in the preparation session which is
if you if you see anything scary don't
try to get away from it you know step
right up to that monster and say what
are you doing in my head or what have
you got to teach me and and it's very
good advice and or surrender you know
relax your mind and float downstream you
know these all these mantras they give
you and they're actually really helpful
and I was all right I just have to
surrender this and I got deeper into the
experience and then I uh
am I going too slow in this narrative is
this okay this is great I'm in okay no
rush okay and then I was it was very
powerful for a while and I was getting a
little nervous about it and I thought
I'm gonna take off my eye shades I'm
wearing these eye shades and one of the
great things about the eye shades is
there are powerful technology I mean
much more powerful than you can imagine
more powerful than VR virtual reality
which is not that powerful but you know
it sends you inside so if you take it
off and I took it off just to make sure
reality was still existing
and and to reorient myself and also
because I had a P you know suddenly I
saw the you know the room I was in and
the guide and the plants and the walls
and the furniture I was like hi reality
I love it and and but I had to pee and I
and I went to the she knew squirted me
of the bathroom because I could barely
move and when I came back and I did
definitely didn't want to look in the
mirror I was really nervous of what I
would see and and I didn't want to look
at her either and I was just like I peed
I produced this described as the
spectacular crop of diamonds because
everything had this beam of light that
was you know being addressed directly to
me and then I came back and she said did
I want a booster dose and I said yes and
I looked at her for the first time as
she was kneeling next to me and she
holds out her hands another mushroom and
she has transformed she's normally
blonde and she had and her hair turned
black and she was this old Mexican
Indian and she had she had morphed into
Maria sabina this legendary figure and
psychedelic history who gave Gordon
Wasson the the the first person first
Westerner to ever try psilocybin his
ceremony in Oaxaca back in the in the
50s and she had turned into this person
and her hands were leathery and her face
was stretched over her cheekbones it was
quite shocking and I and I had to look
away and I didn't want to tell her what
had happened to her
so I take this stepped-up dose and when
I do that and then I go back under and I
put on the the shades the eye shades
again I have this sense of dissolution
that my identity has just exploded into
a thousand little slips of paper like
like little post-its and I was watching
it just get blown to the wind and but I
wasn't panicking I had no desire to to
reassemble you know collect all the
paper and put it back in a pile it was
like no this is fine
and
I realized that that's what was
happening and there was nothing to be
done but surrender to it and that my
sense of self was falling apart before
my eyes but what does that mean how can
your sense of self who's my eyes who's
perceiving this and then it got even
more extreme and I saw myself spread out
over the landscape like a coat of paint
or butter and I was totally fine with it
that was the kind of most amazing thing
and and I can't explain what exactly
happened because my ego was out there
but there was still an eye to take in
the scene and the lesson of it was that
you know what had what should have felt
like this personal cataclysm total loss
of self
there was no category labeled personal
anymore and I was able to perceive this
whole scene with this dispassionate
objectivity it was like that's the way
it is unperturbed and it was this new I
had had access to this amazing vantage
point and it made me realize I'm not
identical to my ego you know that
chattering voice in her head that
accompanies us most of the time it's
kind of neurotic and can be annoying but
is useful too I mean it you know your
ego is what gets the book written but uh
but I had completely separated from it
and I hadn't been annihilated that was
the amazing thing so that to me was the
big takeaway from this experience there
were other things that happened I had a
much happier experience with music
toward the end after constantly fighting
with Mary name I give the guide about
her musical taste we finally agreed and
she put on these Bach unaccompanied
cello suites which are you know it's a
yo-yo ma recording it's just they're
stunning and they're depressing they're
really mournful infinitely sad pieces of
music just - cello nothing else and now
that I was in this non-dual state to
listen to music I mean those words don't
describe what happens it's to become
music you become I D
with the music and I became identical at
various times with the the Bo the
horsehair Bo
you know surfing over those strings of
that cello and then I went into the
cello and you know that mouth of space
that's where all those vibrations come
from and had a total mystical merging
with this piece of music and and to
listen to this music now sends chills up
my spine because I had it wasn't yo-yo
ma it wasn't bought it was like this
universe and I was of it so what does
that all mean you know it was a powerful
lesson in the role of our ego I think in
our lives and that's what I talked about
the next day when I came back for the
integration session I said I had I
realized that there might be another
ground on which to plant our feet
besides this ego this self-interested
ego and but I didn't know what to do
with it because my ego was back on
patrol you know pretty quickly you know
doing its usual thing keeping you know
my unconscious a day and making me
understand that I am me and that's
somebody else and all the stuff it does
but she said and it was interesting she
said well you've had the experience of
not reacting as your ego normally would
that that you know because the ego is
kind of trigger-happy right its
defensive by definition it it marshals
all your defenses and you're supposedly
in your interest and sometimes it is in
your interest but that I'd had a taste
of what it was like to not be the victim
of those trigger reactions and she said
that's something you can cultivate and
and I've been cultivating it ever since
so that was for me that was big news
that was a big insight for me and
and I think about that a lot and I and I
think it has to some extent changed my
relationship to my ego I can I I know
when he's up to his old tricks sometimes
and I can spot it and and sometimes I
can put him in his place
and that's useful now you know
thirty years of psychoanalysis you could
probably get to the same place you do a
lot of work on your ego but this I did
in four hours or five hours so that was
a I now look back on that as a very
positive experience that taught me
something important that also gave me I
mean it was a spiritual experience and
I'm not someone who's had a lot of them
but that merging with the the music was
as powerful spiritual experiences I've
had and it also gave me a little insight
into what is spiritual experience you
know that term has always kind of
mystified me and I think it's no
different I mean I hate to put it in
these psychodynamic terms and I don't
mean to demean anyone's more mystical
understanding of it but to me it's mr.
mystical or spiritual experience is what
happens when your ego is put aside a
spiritual experience is about a sense of
merging with something larger than you
and it's your ego that stands in the way
and to the extent that you can subdue it
or just put it off to the side for a few
hours
amazing things happen and you realize
that you are part of a larger entity and
that the mind of Bach or yo-yo ma is
completely accessible to you and and
that was a big deal to so wild it's hard
for me to even respond to that because
as you noted I thought you did a very
masterful job of describing these
experiences in the book if one of the
hallmarks of mystical experience is
ineffability it poses a quite a
challenge a challenge to put into prose
and I think that if we think about froze
and words also you mentioned the
psychotherapy and certainly there's
absolutely a role to be played and a
function for many of these other
modalities but it strikes me that
they're not mutually exclusive but these
these very difficult to describe
psychedelic experiences
allow people oftentimes to feel things
or to embody things to experience things
that that would be very hard to talk
themselves to as a gingerbread trail to
a conclusion that then allows them to
intellectually change their behavior or
relationship to their ego things like
that I mean there are certain things
that are difficult to talk your way out
of if you didn't talk your way into them
and I'm fascinated by our hope hope to
certainly learn more about why these why
these things seem to have the effect
that they do and our understanding is so
partial but looking at say you mentioned
the treatment-resistant depression
there's a study at Hopkins also that
I've been involved with for the last you
know year a year year and a half and the
for instance there's a if anyone is
interested in throwing their hat in the
ring there's an unfunded study at this
point at Hopkins they're considering
looking at Alzheimer's and even the
potential I think they would be looking
mostly at its effects on depression and
anxiety but there there are some people
who have postulated that there may be a
role in neurogenesis in the hippocampus
and we're in effect at least from
psilocybin which is really tantalizing
of course I mean selfishly speaking I
have Alzheimer's on both sides of my
family some interest in that but if we
if we zoom out from the these individual
studies have you thought about how these
drugs this these these classes might
intersect with broader societal
opportunities or threats at all I mean
not the pie in the sky yeah yeah or
anything like that or to avoid that you
know I mean we have pathologies at the
individual level and we have pathologies
at the civilizational level or the
national level and what's striking to me
is that the two biggest I think the two
biggest challenges we face as a as a
culture are the environmental crisis
and tribalism there other words you can
put on that but let's use tribalism both
of which are functions of ego
consciousness in that what we do to
nature has a lot to do with the fact
that we objectify nature and that we
think of ourselves as the only subject
and everything else is an object
therefore for our use
same with tribalism that too is the
sense of a you know an ego patrolling a
border and that everything on this side
is us and we will protect it and
everything on that side we're in a
zero-sum contest with so these drugs you
know offer an antidote to both those
ways of thinking and it is no accident
I'm sure that the the fact that the 60s
you know represented the birth of
environmentalism yes there was you know
Rachel Carson and the Cuyahoga River on
fire and all the other things that were
happening then but psychedelic
consciousness also may have contributed
to environmental consciousness because
one of the things that happens is that
the world becomes animate in a way it
wasn't before and that the plants and
the animals and the fungi all have their
points of view - and you feel very
connected in a way that makes it hard to
be destructive and same with people I
mean you feel connected to all different
kinds of people so you know I'm not
suggesting we need to put these drugs in
the water supply there might be some
individuals that we can all think of who
would benefit enormously if they were
willing to undergo this sort of therapy
but they're I think they're extremely
relevant to the moment we're in and the
problems were struggling with and
perhaps it's no accident that this
Renaissance is coming about at the time
it is you mentioned the drinking water
let's talk about it for a second so
there are there are I've observed as I'm
sure you have people who are
militant proselytizers of psychedelics
who are are prone to the same type of
rhetoric that seemed to cause a lot of
trouble in in the earlier iteration of
all this and the in the 60s putting it
in the drinking water making it legal
you want to go to 7-eleven and just get
a
LSD smoothie seems like a bad idea to me
then you have people on the far other
end of the spectrum
certainly in not-too-distant history who
would not even if consider publishing a
scientific study involving psychedelics
wouldn't even consider the scientific
merit of a study and we we seem to be in
a very well as you put it at Renaissance
where the research is finally being done
to clarify the mechanisms of action and
the you know the potential but also the
risks of these of these drugs and it's
so exciting to me having really spent so
much time as you have looking at this
what are the ways that people can screw
this up do you know what I mean because
it's just I really really think we have
an incredible opportunity to decipher
how these plants and compounds that have
in many cases existed well certainly
existed but been consumed for millennia
and how they fit into a world that is
bursting at the seams with not
decreasing but increasing prevalence of
certain types of mental health problems
and other issues it's it just it's such
an opportunity that I don't want to see
wasted
how can people screw it up and what
would you is there anything you would
ask of people certainly I would say to
people don't go don't find some shaman
unlike casual encounters on Craigslist
and order mail order god knows what from
the dark web and just decide to do it
with your friends on a weekend a
terrible terrible terrible idea among
others yeah and and and you know going
down in Peru and with the first you know
shaman you meet I mean there have been
horrible stories coming out of Peru
you know you know sexual assault of
women and there was a murder the other
day involving a healer and in Peru so I
think carelessness is the great threat
and I think carelessness is part of what
doomed psychedelics in the 60s or
temporarily doing them in the 60s you
know one of the great lessons if you if
you study history is that until our own
time when psychedelics came along and we
didn't have any sort of conventions or
rules to govern their use and many
people to get into trouble and the
psychedelics themselves you know ignited
a catalyzed two kind of backlash but you
go in history and you see that these
powerful substances were only used in a
very controlled considered way and that
you didn't have individuals taking them
on their own there was always a circle
there were always elders there was the
shaman there was the person who had lots
of experience of the territory
administering it to people it was always
organized in a ritual there was a
ceremony on all these cultural forms I'm
not saying those ones are right and we
should simply adapt those or adopt those
they may not be right to Western culture
we may have to come up with our own
rituals our own ceremonies our own rules
of the road for these drugs and I think
that to some extent that was the failure
of the sixties now I don't want to paint
it with a broad brush there are many
people who had wonderful experiences
with psychedelics in the 60s who had
important insights and and and and
created a you know great art as a result
of their experiences but for the culture
as a whole it led to this backlash and
and and a fair amount of suffering and
also the loss of 30 years of good
research that we could have been doing
and I think that had to do with the fact
that we did not have a proper cultural
container so the question we now face is
what is that container one of them is
the medical system that's the path that
on it and y-you and Hopkins I don't
think that's the only path
I agree strongly with Bob Jessie who's
you know one of the motive forces behind
the revival of research who says you
know yes there are people who are
suffering and we have to help them but
these drugs are also good for what he
calls the betterment of well people
people like myself people like yourself
and that it would be a shame if their
use was restricted only to toward people
with you know DSM diagnosis of one kind
or another so what's the proper vessel
for them is it is it a religious
festival vessel well that's not
comfortable with everybody we need to
figure this out
you know the Greeks apparently used a
psychedelic and the mysteries of Eleusis
or the Elysian mysteries as they're
called was a was an annual Rite where
everyone who wanted to in the culture
well not the not the slaves but not just
the elite used something called the
kikiyaon which was a psychedelic
apparently and they had visions and they
went to the you know the after world of
the underworld and it was a very
powerful annual Rite you were not
allowed to use the kikiyaon
any other time in fact somebody once did
they got to hold the Sun and they had a
party and they were severely punished
for doing this because they understood
that this had to be taken in the best
interest of the whole society in a way
that was carefully regulated and so I
think that's where we find ourselves I
think that the is figuring out a way to
use these drugs to make them accessible
to more people but to contain their
risks and to house them in a cultural
form that's appropriate to them and
appropriate to us that I think is how
you prevent the kind of carelessness
that led to trouble you know I mean I
think Leary's sin if he had one was
giving up on the idea of a guide and and
I think that the the guide whether it's
you know a friend who stays close to
ground or somebody preferably very
all trained and experienced makes all
the difference and especially as you get
older I think where you're less of a
risk taker people in their 20s will do
the craziest things I mean look at the
way they drive let along the way they
take drugs but as you get older working
with a guide is a is at least it was for
me made the experience created a space
in which I could surrender and and put
down all my defenses I'm not gonna do
that you know walking around Manhattan
and so we have a lot of work to do
designing the experience and
understanding what the drugs are doing
but designing the experience in a way
that is safe and conducive to the kind
of work we want to do it's such an
exciting area of exploration I'm
cautiously optimistic I am too I'm
cautiously optimistic and you and I have
both interviewed people and heard these
stories of transformation not just
anecdotal but also in very controlled
scientific environments and you also
hear stories as I'm sure you have I
heard a story recently and I was talking
about the Phase three trials with
someone and their nephew who is I want
to say 18 or 19 probably getting the age
wrong doesn't really matter for the
purposes of illustrating but he has he
has suffered from severe OCD for many
years which has been debilitating smart
kid did a ton of research went on to
PubMed ultimately determined that for
him see he thought psilocybin might be a
tool to help mitigate his OCD and it
worked
mm-hmm but due to the legal
classification he was caught with
mushrooms and expelled from school and
it's just so tragic in a case like that
that these tools are not available to
those who could benefit and I really
hope that people will at the very least
consider the importance of
scientifically
exploring these things and there's so
many different angles of examination but
that's that's certainly one at the very
least I mean supporting those who are
attempting to understand how these
things do what they do and I have to
commend you for putting this book
together and I mentioned this to you in
person
some time ago but there was
simultaneously great relief and great
kind of hand to the the forehead because
you you saved me from attempting to
write would have no no doubt been a far
inferior book so I really appreciate you
taking the the time and also the the
bringing on board and not relinquishing
your skepticism as you explored this
entire world in this subject matter I
really think that it is it is such a
critical subject at such a critical time
so I I not only I'm not I don't get any
Vig on this certainly recommend people
read it themselves but it's it's it's
it's a book that I think is mind
expanding on so many levels even if you
never have any interest in consuming a
psychedelic of any type it is a it is an
incredible lens through which to learn
more about the mind and more about
ultimately your entire experience of
reality as far as we know is filtered
through this thing we hold between our
ears so getting to know it better
certainly seems in everyone's best
interest but I really appreciate all the
time that you've taken today and hope we
can talk about this many more times but
besides besides people reading the book
which everyone should I really it's it's
I've read many of your books it is my
favorite of your books it's such a
difficult tightrope to walk and he and
you really you really did an excellent
job in so many ways
do you have any parting comments
suggestions asks of the audience you
know I you know it's funny people have
asked me or am I an advocate for
psychedelics and
and the answer is no not yet I'm an
advocate as you just said I thought you
said quite eloquently the research we
have to support the research there is
enormous potential here but it still has
a long way to go we haven't answered all
the questions as you say this is a book
and this is a an enterprise speaking
larger than the book up to understand
the mind it's not to understand
psychedelics psychedelics are a tool as
stanislav grof said all those years ago
they are a really powerful tool to
understand the mind and potentially your
mind and so you know I think is keep
keep abreast of the research read some
of these papers read some of rava
Carhartt Harris's papers and and you
know there are more books to be written
about it to them I don't think you
should give up on that idea you should
just wait a little bit there's so much
to be said it is such I feel like I got
every now and then as a writer you get
lucky and you hit the the right type of
topic at the right moment and I just
felt like oh my god I'm a kid in the
candy store I have this amazing subject
I'm learning so many things I didn't
know and it was the most exciting
experience I've had as a writer and and
I'm hoping you know that the reader
feels the same way yeah you paddled you
paddled for the wave at the right time
I think end up for for everybody
listening as I alluded to earlier I will
include links to not only the book but
some of the studies like the the
entropic brain and everything that we
talked about I will include to image you
the international absolutely I'll
include links to all of those things in
the show notes which you just find it
tim-tom log forward slash podcast and
search pollen and you it'll pop right up
and I just want to thank you too for
your I mean you know it's wonderful to
be interviewed by somebody who is so
deeply informed on the subject and so
passionate so thank you for your time
and and the amount of thought you put
into it and for reading
book early and I'm very grateful
entirely my pleasure
and to be continued so I know you have a
busy few weeks and months ahead so yeah
it's gonna be crazy and I encourage your
your your listeners and readers to come
to one of my events I'm doing I don't
know 20 events in the next month all
over the country and if you go to my
website or Michael Pollan calm the
schedule is there and please come and
introduce yourself wonderful I will
encourage everybody do that they can
also say hello to you on Twitter at
Michael Pollan and I'll include your
other social handles as well in the show
notes I will let you get back to your
day good sir
but wonderful to share this time with
you and thank you again for writing the
book I really I really think it's it's
it's an impressive resource end story so
thank you very much and thanks for
shining a light on I really appreciate
it all right and for you and I hope til
soon and everybody listening until next
time hey guys this is Tim again just a
few more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet Friday do
you want to get a short email from me
and would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday event
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read
and that I've shared with my close
friends for instance and it's very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's four hour work week comm all
spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by helix
sleep last year I committed to making
sleep a top priority trying to fix onset
insomnia or continuing to fix that depth
of sleep quality of sleep I tracked a
lot and tested a lot and I revisited
really everything from daily routine to
these surfaces I slept on playing with
Ashley pad whatever and when I moved to
Austin I got all new beds including
mattresses from helix working with the
world's leading sleep experts certainly
some of them helix leapt at all
mattresses personalized to your
preferences and sleep style to make sure
that you can have the best sleep
possible without costing thousands upon
thousands of dollars helix sleep has
recently had a new layer customized
sleep with the helix pillow the all new
pillows are fully adjustable so you can
achieve perfect comfort regardless of a
sleep position or body type or if you're
a shifty type like me I move around
quite a bit when I sleep just take their
simple two to three minutes sleep quiz
to get started and that will help ensure
that they can build a mattress or pillow
that you
of the mattress whatever this bespoke
mattress is that you arrive at will get
to you within a week and the shipping is
completely free you can try the mattress
for 100 nights and if you're not
completely happy they'll pick it up and
offer a full refund I tested that refund
policy because I test all of these
sponsors and kick the tires a lot we
tested it and they came through on
making sure that we got ultimately the
right mattress for my body type to
personalize your sleep experience visit
helix sleep combo and slash Tim and
you'll receive up to $125 off your
mattress order that's helix sleep hgl is
sleep comp or slash Tim for up to $125
off your order
this episode is brought to you by teeter
I am so thrilled to have connected with
these guys because I've used teeter
products for many many years I've
traveled around the country and the
world with cheaper products and I'm
sitting about 15 feet in my home from
one of their inversion tables and we're
gonna talk more about all of that
one of my originals is hanging and I
should say not only that it's a
maintenance and performance program I
hang not just in the morning potentially
but particularly after a day of bearing
weight whether that includes
weight training in Jersey Greg Rex world
record holder insists on this type of
conversion therapy after training or
just wearing heavy backpack around a few
minutes goes a long way towards that our
sleep in my case less back pain neck
and leg pain it's not a panacea
obviously but inversion therapy which
uses gravity and your own bodyweight
decompress the spine or relieve pressure
on the discs and surrounding nerves
seems to help with a whole slew of
conditions and just as a general
maintenance program it's one of my
favorite things to do so what to say
about that
Peter why Teeter Teeter is the best
known name in inversion table since 1981
more than 3 million people have put
their trust in Teeter Teeter is also the
only inversion table brand that has been
both safety certified by Underwriters
Laboratories XUL people in that industry
will recognize it and registered with
the FDA as a class 1 medical device and
they're giving a very special offer just
to you guys my listeners for a limited
time you can get the teeter inversion
table with bonus accessories which I
have a bunch of again in the room next
to me and a free pair of gravity boots
so that you can invert at home or take
the boots with you to the gym so these
gravity boots I have three separate
pairs of gravity boots bought with my
own money in three different cities that
I've had for a very very long time
because I don't want to travel with them
necessarily it looks kind of like ski
boots but without the foot portion and
they cook you upside down so you can
take them really anywhere you want to go
to get this deal which is a savings of
over one hundred and forty eight dollars
it's very specific
so maybe 249 you have to go to Teeter
comm forward slash Tim that's teeter
calm full-size empty btter you also see
a free shipping a 60-day money back
guarantee and free returns so why not
try it out remember you can only get the
teeter inversion table with bonus
accessories and a free pair of grammar
boots by going to teeter com1 slash tim
so if you're thinking yourself what the
hell is this thing he's talking about i
can't even envision it in my head well
take a look at the photos go to teeter
comp forward slash hip
you
you